the what do you call it uh
yesterday i posted this on twitter if
you can go to my twitter account i just
kind of want to share with this
uh last night i i i'm really zoom in a
little bit more so we can see it yeah go
a little lower so justin trudeau's video
keep going keep going keep going keep
going so he says this message here
and i tweeted it out and i said why just
guns nearly 1900 fatalities last year
from car accidents in canada while 277
fatalities from guns in the same year
since you're so concerned about the
lives of people let's get real tough and
ban all cars right because that's seven
times the amount of people that died
from cars than they did with guns sure
so so the solution isn't to just say
well you know
let's ban all guns okay fine so his
proposal uh that he proposes limits on
size of magazines i think it's five
rounds nobody should have more than five
rounds harsher criminal penalties for
trafficking guns fine a red flag gun gun
law stripping firearm licenses from
people involved in domestic violence
okay that's kind of what he wants to do
then if you go above it and i kind of
want to run this by you as well go a
little higher so i asked a question i
post post a video that we had with
catalina laugh if you remember when we
talked about what happened in santa toni
go a little higher go a little higher go
a little higher that one right there
click on that one so i said okay so if
if cause both sides they're so emotional
you you're not gonna take away my guns
you know you're gonna have to go through
my
m16 if you want to take my gun you can
and we how can you be so this and you
know and there's no way do you not
understand lives were lost so i said
okay perfect how would you improve or
reform our current gun laws in us
comment below and like the ones you you
like the most so i want to kind of read
you what some of the people on twitter
said yesterday just kind of get your
feet so first one says
get to get the mentally ill people the
help they need kind of like what you
just talked about
make constitutional carry the law in all
50 states you can tell where that guy
leans
repeal the nfa i think you want to say
nra but maybe saying the nfa repeal atf
okay go show more replies so we can see
it give everyone bb guns he's trying to
be funny educating our society first
fine mandatory safety training
takes a few hours provides a certificate
and send them home with a locking case
for the firearm doesn't seem
unreasonable to train people who are
buying guns
psych meds equals no firearms i kind of
agree with that one keep going lower uh
gta 5 kill go okay well morality let's
see what the next first and foremost i
would prohibit big pharma to market
directly to consumer that's a complete
different conversation right mental
health is the issue not guns goes back
to what you're saying mental health or
not so much the problem is the ease of
accessibility to buy guns because people
with mental health will always be there
so let's find a way to stop these people
from acting on their evil thoughts okay
six month wait list that's a long time
background checks and national register
this kid planned this for two years how
does that change or stop anything good
argument counter argument to him i would
say let's revoke every unconstitutional
law in 50 states dc and territories
let as many people as one to any place
in america conceal carry murders and
murderers and criminals would soon
change their bad habits what do you
think about that that's an interesting
take i don't think we have a gun law
issue i think we have a law influence
enforcement issue
any form of gun control is
unconstitutional abolish all forms of
gun laws anyways this keeps going on
somebody said 25 years old same age as
renting a car then the argument back is
well if an 18 year old can go to war why
should an 18 euro be able to carry a gun
well then are we more comfortable with
an 18 year old carrying a gun uh rather
than carrying a beer because alcohol is
21 years old in many states right so the
part here is both sides seems to be seem
to be screaming off the top of their
lungs on what they want no one is really
willing to sit down and have a
conversation about it which argument
have you seen from the
side that is not the conservative side
that you've said i think they do have
some kind of a point should we increase
the age should we do a little bit more
training before somebody can just buy a
gun or leave the place
what should we do to improve uh some of
the issues when surrounding guns
i agree with the idea that if you're
getting psycho psycho
drug treatment for
psychological problems uh you know that
that should be
uh
automatically prohibitive in terms of
gun ownership
i agree with uh you know people who are
respond guilty of domestic violence you
know uh you know that that uh that that
uh uh that should restrict you know
firearms ownership
and i'm answering your question because
you asked me
what solutions have come from the left
okay that i would agree with
but most solutions from the left i don't
agree with
my bias is always to give more freedom
to people not less
i said earlier that i do believe in
background checks i do providing they're
not abused by government and you always
have to suspect government because the
inclination in government like for
example in washington dc where they
abuse background checks in new york city
to the point where they are
basically rescinding people's second
amendment rights and that's not right uh
you know government has proven itself
so
greedy of power
uh uh you know and
and most americans the population that
is all for gun control and all the rest
they don't under understand
uh or maybe they just don't care uh you
know that the second amendment is there
for a reason it's not for recreation
it's not for sports and hunting it's
because in the federalist papers when we
were convinced when the colonies were
convinced to form a federal government
with a government in washington
that we needed an armed citizenry to be
the last bastion of defense against
tyranny you know the
the
constitution and the second amendment
that's in there was written by a
revolutionary generation the first
battle of the american revolution was a
question of over over firearms you know
the british were going
to lexington and concord to confiscate
the malicious guns and gunpowder and
disarm the citizenry so they could be
oppressed and the founders knew that so
this business is about second amendment
rights you know being for hunting
rights and recreational that's not why
we have a second amendment it's because
the people
and we know this not just in our own
american revolution
but you know in every
tyranny that has arisen in history
they try to disarm the people and make
them sheep so that they are powerless
against the government so we need to be
extremely protective of the of the power
i think people i think the gun laws are
too restrictive in terms of the types of
firearms not only should this business
about limiting magazines no
you know
are
i think you can make a a good practical
and constitutional case uh that
americans should be allowed to own
firearms that are equivalent to
military-grade firearms because really
yeah because of that role
now do you think america needs more guns
or less guns
i think it needs more good guns you know
what does that mean i think it needs
more guns so that if it became necessary
to have a second american revolution the
average american would stand a chance
you know the average sporting rifle or
or shotgun
take it do a test sometime and take it
out to a firing range and see how many
rounds you can put through it before it
starts jamming up you'll find that a
sporting rifle you know actually
uh can't do sustained fire for very long
but you're saying that americans need
more militaristic type weapons in
average american hands
yeah what reason
to fight against government because i'm
increasingly fearful that we're heading
toward a tyranny and uh and that there's
and the reason the government wants to
confiscate guns and restrict gun
ownership is because they want to they
want to have a tyranny over us you know
there's a faction that says we already
have way too many guns here in the
united states i mean i think we have
tyler i think i sent you some of these
stats we have four percent of the
world's population
what percentage of the world's guns do
you think we have
i don't know i don't take a guess
you know
fifty percent that's a that's exactly
right we have four percent of the
world's population
we have fifty percent of the world's
firearms you say that we should have
more and more
um do you know militaristic type guns in
switzerland i don't know i'm just
stating facts i'm not like i'm just
giving yeah
i am saying that i'm saying there's i
see no reason
in a constitutional republic where the
people are supposed to be in charge okay
and that we don't belong to the
government we're not the property of the
government we're supposed to be free
independent people
that we need to have the ability to
protect our liberties and protect
ourselves from our own government which
has become increasing increasingly
intrusive and oppressive uh you know uh
and uh
uh
and and and and the trend to the trend
line uh is is going away from being a
constitutional republic to becoming a
tyrian i don't think we're actually a
constitutional republic anymore i think
we're currently a tyranny but we're in
the soft faces of tyranny but isn't the
biggest problem right now protecting
innocent kids not so much the government
trying to come after you well that's
that's certainly the the biggest
immediate problem because we've had this
issue but i think
thinking people have to take a longer
view
and uh and and it's uh in addition to
protecting our children and our children
by the way i think have to be protected
from our government too
you know i am extremely
of course it's tragic that though that
those children were killed by that
person by that mentally deranged person
but it wasn't
it wasn't the gun that killed those
people it was the public policy the
government has followed that has put
lunatics like that out in the street and
government has changed the policies so
that so that our our situation is more
dangerous
i'm very concerned about
a government
you know that thinks that child abuse
institutionalized child abuse is okay
and that's what we've got when you're
teaching kindergartners through third
graders for example about transsexuality
and having conversation and expecting
teachers to educate our children on
matters that
when i was growing up if a stranger in a
park came up to you and started talking
to you about the things that we have our
encourage our elementary school teachers
to talk to our children about that
person would be arrested as a child
predator you know but we have government
sanctioning that and doing that to our
children you know i'm not really that
pervasive of a problem i get that
there's some teachers that do that but
is that
is that sort of a straw man approach
that all these nobody's not going to be
sir sir it is not a straw man it's being
done all across the country parents all
across the country are up in arms and
being arrested in school board meetings
for trying to protect their children
from child abuse you know by the way if
i may there is
way more of that happening
than
uh yes the gun
issues that we're having just so you
know there is not even 10 times more
there's way more what issues there's way
more of the teachers trying to influence
kids way of thinking with what he's
talking about with transgenderism
there's a hundred times more of that
happening
than the issue with guns but the
government's not putting their attention
there the government's going straight to
guns
let's address guns let's not think about
the long-term ramifications of shifting
the way kids think we're not thinking
about that we're thinking about the
finite war not the infinite war there's
a big difference between a finite war
and an infinite war so i agree with that
part there on
uh what he's saying where you're going
with this
in regards to guns can you put up that
one thing you put up by the way you said
four percent and 50 somebody could say
you know we are four percent of the
world's population but we are twenty
percent the wealth okay then what do you
say about that right you know so so
we're much we're that much freer than
the rest of the world because we unlike
the rest of the world uh you know own
guns so the fact that we own fifty
percent of the world's guns if that's
true i don't know that it is but let me
point out some other things okay five
minutes left go ahead all right in
switzerland you know every adult male
you know who is part of the swiss
militia who can surf in the military is
required to have an automatic
military-grade uh uh weapon an assault
rifle a real assault rifle in their
house uh you know with hundreds of
rounds of ammunition so that if they're
called up that's switzerland which has
some of the lowest uh gun crime
so-called gun crime they they phrase it
in the world in the 19th century before
we had the kind of modern gun laws that
we have now where
carrying firearms was very commonplace
among people
you know we
the crime the murder rates and the rest
were much lower than they are today
you know this does it isn't the guns
that are causing the crime uh you know
it's the it's the culture that's causing
the crime and uh you know and i think
that a lot of this is correlated with uh
uh
the destruction of our culture because
of big government in the role that it
plays which is increasingly which is
increasingly destructive yes we need to
be armed to protect ourselves from an
increasingly predatory government
you know that is uh that is frankly not
a constitutional republic as i said
before and why did i say that
that's because in order to have a
constitutional republic you need to at
least two political parties both
political parties everybody has to obey
the law and respect the constitution
we i think we cease to be a
constitutional republic at least from
the first year of the trump
administration with the democrat party
engaged in
unconstitutional and illegal behavior by
bringing false charges against president
trump that he was a russian agent and
that he needed to be invest they knew
that was a lie they abused the law they
abused the constitution to undermine a
political opponent
and uh and i think the 2020 elections
were also stolen you know by the
democrat party i think people anybody
who hasn't watched 2 000 meals should
watch it but i think you don't even have
to watch that just common sense would
tell you that a guy like biden
who has
i don't know how many times he ran for
president three four times and he never
got more than two percent of the vote
now we're expected to believe that he
got more votes than any president in
american history the 2020 elections were
stolen so many will tell you that that's
because they trump was hated that much
more people voting against him
than voting for him
yeah well that's what they that's what
they say but watch two thousand mules
and see what happened we had dinner
before but so yeah so okay this this
article right switzerland has won the
highest rates of gun ownership in the
world but little gun related street
crime so opponents uh some opponents of
gun control hail it as a place where
firearms play a positive role in society
however swiss gun
uh culture is unique and guns are more
tightly regulated than many assume okay
for me the one part where
the right has to
use a little bit of
um
i don't know how to from from my
standpoint there is nothing wrong with
requiring a little bit of training
there's nothing wrong with giving me a
one-day training
two-day training where i gotta get a
sign-off where i gotta go to something
where i gotta go shoot or have somebody
that's teaching me the basics a former
vet or former military i don't know i
think just sitting around and saying
yeah it's it's not a big deal it's not
this is i i would much rather have a
hundred percent of people that are on
non-meds non-domestic violence
non-mental issues a hundred percent of
adults
have a gun or a weapon that they are
trained to use
then have fifty percent of america that
are able to buy guns
and they have no experience to have any
kind of weapons you know training or how
to use it i'd much rather drive training
my idea is to drive training drive
education drive being in a community to
say do this be careful with this when
you're making a left turn with a car
look at this mirror 10-2 basic stuff
that we learned at 16 years old those 10
20 basic things to teach somebody with
guns that you can also tell them you
know certain things i i think there are
some things we can do to improve in that
area so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]
you